yep
huh it's Monday it's a new year and I'm
ready to make this the best show of the
year
um and uh I've got my Phil's Coffee I'm
gonna be honest with you they put a
little too much sugar in there a little
mocha now what I want to do is start
living on raw meat not raw but but you
know grass-fed beef because I had that
luxury
and uh all the while knowing that
grass-fed beef isn't a reality if we
want to feed this many bodies you need
factory farming so anybody who thinks
that you can live on grass-fed beef
doesn't know how their food is brought
to their tummy
and I didn't either until I read some
things recently so believe me I'm just a
little smarter than you are because I've
read recently and that doesn't mean I'm
smarter I just have that information the
point is
um I'm not going to be doing sugar
anymore I will do caffeine though I've
already had three double espressos so
I'm an addict
are you wearing shoes today I'm wearing
shoes today because I felt like it was a
little chilly and I like the way these
go with this outfit but I don't like
this outfit because I don't like me
so you can put a silk hat on a pig and
the pig is still a pig you understand
you know what I mean you could Bejeweled
that cap
you can get the best cap maker hat maker
on the planet best hat maker on the
planet you put it on a pig and it
doesn't do anything for the pig's look
so yeah I was comparing myself to a pig
yes I am I lost all my looks all of them
you look great right I don't think so
but I appreciate that and I like your
attitude
at least you still got your oink I got
my oink I still got my oink and that's
what George says I got my point
did you get my friend keto George over
he was fighting this Saturday oh yes
we're hoping HBO show time or UFC picked
up the the programming rights with the
decline it's their loss right there he
has a fight this Saturday you feel a
fight that's right dude Commerce a 42
year old uh other guy that did the
beginners 42 year old bees don't don't
downplay this George you've been trading
over about 30 weeks now just the Ulta
program him or what in what MMA MMA
everything yeah have you been teaching
him anything yeah I came in there and
gave him a little something came up with
the game plans for him really they've
been training it's the Alta program and
you're gonna have a fight that's
incredible dude yes we'll put up on the
show chin is gonna be there that's
exciting uh Rick Ross P Diddy front row
uh Oscar De La Hoya Jake Paul should be
pretty big Commerce I think it's
Commerce City California
yeah all right if they lose they can't
come back so that's cool you gotta win
Georgie I'm gonna have to win your job's
on the line
is
the fighter in the kit this is really
the fighter and the kid come on baby
now I want to be the first one you know
he's asking if we're ready I want to
welcome you into the new year 2000
23. it took you way too long it's weird
to say huh it's very weird time seems to
I was uh 40 about five months ago now I
want to say this uh you you uh I think
on New Year's you sent me the most
boring video of all time and that was
just you with a fish tank
filling it up in fact no it was just a
fish tank that had already been filled
up that's yesterday just I saw the
filter on it and I was like there it is
and you said getting three fish tanks no
is normal yeah I said it is because last
time we did this pod before we went to
Boston I had at the time I had one fish
tank big question I'm not currently have
three well big ready 75 gallon but let
me see if I had something 75 gallon
that's where the big boys a lot but
that's going through the nitrogen
process it's gonna take about two weeks
before I cannot fish that's it really
here two weeks before you got a
nitronize you got a nitronize look at
that and that's fish food in there
because you want the bacteria to start
going but you want fish safe before you
put it in there oh you need bacteria
yeah oh the bacteria to fight the
ammonia and the nitrates yeah oh so you
got to hold that water at a particular
pH pH and then we need about 78 to 80
degrees if you're getting cichlids okay
yeah you're getting cichlids yeah I'm
getting a flower child secretary I have
two if you do more than two they they
team up on the other fish yeah then the
Oscars Lee whatever yeah now did I have
a lobster murdered yeah I did dude you
did I did you already you already
there's already been Foul Play in your
fish tank but not to because I didn't do
my due diligence because these fish are
[ __ ] I have one fish I call Manson
he's Charles Manson and he aligned all
these other followers oh boy and they
ripped the hands off the lobster what
and then I thought what I went this
isn't good I'm putting back another tank
where the fish are nicer and there's no
uh Oscars or like aggressive cichlids
because it's a leopard cichlid you know
this territorial [ __ ] so I take the
the lobster without the claws and I
researched it did you know this about
lobsters they can regenerate generalize
this is great so I put them in the other
tank yeah pulling the other those fish
went hold on he can't pinch us anymore
you got a stranger now what's you got a
stranger with a little Pinchers what's
Red Lobster baby and we eating scampi
tonight we eating scampi tonight no and
ain't no say fish ain't no say fish if
you're a lobster I thought lobsters
ruled ruled the deep but they don't he
he was about you know about three inches
you put him in as a baby well yeah I
have three babies in there his problem
is with leopard cichlids dude but the
other lobsters are fine because they
would hide they had places to hide this
Lobster is out and about like this
he doesn't know what them gills do baby
he's a baby what them gills do baby so
you took the you know I took off a baby
number one already I didn't do that so
you let his pitchers get bit off Manson
poor little guys are all messed up then
you put them in another tank now he's a
Stranger in a Strange Land and then what
happened this is the terrible story then
he went up to the sick living goes oh
what that mouth do and then that cichlid
went what'd it do you know he no and it
and and the only thing I found was a
tail floating in the water you did not I
went to bed I went oh he seems to get
along with everybody and then went good
night Mr shop I went good night and then
the lights went off they went
hey pinch boy
what's up hey pinchless now we remember
when Mr Schaub was around the warden
right yeah the prison cell now you
pinched them when the warden was around
you're talking all that [ __ ] what that
mouth do yeah we're gonna show you what
it do because he forgot let me show you
what to do forgot he didn't have his
Weaponry anymore
killed him
I have to explain that to a six-year-old
and they left the tale that's the best
part yeah they don't care about the tail
so it was it was it was a hate kill it
wasn't even a food kill it was a food
kill they just didn't like the tail or
you know what they might have ate inside
the tail I don't know I just got to
hollowed them out hauled them out what
the [ __ ] man mommy they mummified them
[ __ ] God damn that's a [ __ ]
dangerous tank oh bro and this is still
we're still in fresh water uh yeah yeah
we salt water doesn't come to March
tonight
[Music]
all right we need to see an enemy
bro see an enemy live live Coral they
suck everything in and the la la Coral
scratch it it's all about the filtering
filtration system now did I look into
putting live piranhas in that 75 gallon
tank yeah I did yeah the problem with
the piranha is obviously there's this
whole narrative in Hollywood that you
put your hand in the rip it down to Bone
yeah that's not real right that's never
happened yeah but they are shy I don't
like shy fish I like aggressive fish I
can see swim around and yeah you know
yeah so Piranha's not for me they're too
shy now here's another thing about the
piranha now let's say you go on vacation
you like vacations right and you got a
school piranhas you gotta get a school
you get one that's gonna die you gotta
go to school you know get out of school
fish so you get a piranha you almost
have to have your own tank for piranhas
They can get along with some cell mates
but we'll see right now you just need
their own piranha school of fish yeah
let's say you go on vacation you're gone
for four days fish can last about three
days without food maybe even longer okay
now you go you know what I forgot to
feed the Piranhas I'm gonna feed them
you put your hand over the tank those
piranhas go holy [ __ ] we're starving
these flakes are the guppy fish put in
it's enough how about your finger that's
when you do get your fingers yes when
they're starving is that true yes that's
true some people have a lot of problems
doing that and I went well I have young
children around and they're gonna
probably put their hands in the face so
probably pass
but me and the team came with new ideas
we can't have piranhas a fake boy adults
here could have adults here which would
be hilarious if you put your hand in
that tank and you got bit right so at
the end of the day you if you put your
fingers in a piranha if they're starving
you could have problems chances are you
can be fine there's a small chance that
promise you think your finger is a big
old dick there's also there's also a
chance you might keep you might keep the
ribs on your piranhas
getting ripped up you keep them ripped
up now they're always hungry now I want
them leave somebody comes in thick boy
you don't like their attitude
you pick them up you put them on on a
gurney that lowers their them down you
got them so here's what you do no you do
this is a Dexter yeah I'm on Plank okay
you have a hole for their dong oh just
the wiener and then you lower it into
the tank okay you get all the
information now the minute their dick
hits the water you know I'm singing I'm
telling you everything you want to know
and the [ __ ] I don't know
because I don't want my dick getting
taken out by pit on us an 80 degree tank
that would be such a problem for me oh
right it'd be such a [ __ ] problem now
I like your thinking this is fun the
operation we're going to need to hold an
adult male upside down like that on a
platform is well I don't know you need
to pull these too much and they come in
people with the play system for like we
get weird here man yeah or I just go
people don't get along with me maybe
they don't like my ideas some employees
they go
you enjoy sleeping with the fish no you
go like this and I take their head and
go hey goosh yeah or you saying this to
him you go like this you go yeah you
could go
you just do this you go put them on the
plank
no place
unzip his pants yeah or or yeah or
you're strong enough you grab them by
the back of the hair that's what I'm
thinking that's more realistic face into
it that's way more realistic I don't
have a pulley system Brian I don't know
if the landlord's gonna allow that
either you're not even thinking but
aren't they gonna be like they're gonna
be shrouded in the shot no we're doing
it late at night no the problem is so
hungry you don't care if you shout or
you choke them out and then you put
their face in and they come too like you
have a mirror this is more likely than
the pulley system
pulley system a little little much right
yeah
point is the problem is shy and I don't
want them
yeah but some Oscars be fun
Oscars what's going in your so so in
your salt water tank you got it's a lot
yeah you got now now stay away from the
blue octopus you know this in the box
jellyfish because they're so poisonous
that you'll die you can't have a box
dude
that's my line that's your line people
are asking me oh I'm getting blown up
what's your what's your line wait did
you know about the box jellyfish then of
course okay sorry that's my line that's
why I draw the line it's got to be here
we can't have a box jellyfish no [ __ ]
tank here's the other thing that's all
you're gonna have they just float on top
like this and then their tentacles are
the problem everything everybody here
comes two dice
yeah there's no swimming there's no
enjoying there's no reason anywhere it's
it's it's squid games the whole time and
everybody's gonna well it would be fun
when you come in and be like yeah fish
tank yeah that's a box jellyfish man but
don't see your tank and you die yeah
that's fun yeah centerpiece until you
get like Stevo he'll be like oh my God
no you you go into you go into that's
that's what that's why I draw the line
yeah that's where my line is you're
gonna go through it box jelly let me go
through it uh blue octopus they're small
I would do that
that's the most poisonous creature in
the sea I believe
small it's adorable no they're gonna
like it when you see it the octopus is
worse I'm sorry be the uh the the box
jellyfish is worse blue ringed octopus
he's cute you see how cute that is he's
so cute it's impossibly poisonous I
don't know why
I don't know why they're holding it guys
it bites you you will die it is insanely
poisonous are we sure they bite or they
poisonous highly venomous species
um our four highly benefited species of
octopus that are found in tide pools and
coral groups in the Pacific and Indian
oceans from Japan to Australia told you
Australia of course uh it can inject TTX
to delivering it as a venomen via near
painless I like this bison blue eye ring
octopus they're reasonably rare but
these animals do carry a dose of TTX
that is lethal for humans there have
been a handful of fatal encounters with
these animals
yeah here's the thing that's I would
yeah I'll take one of those you would
yes 100 they're cute as [ __ ] and they're
cool looking I know but you gotta make
sure and they're tidy
tourists play with deadly blue ring
octopus and rage locals yeah yeah I
don't blame it'd be a cool tattoo look
at that thing I would 100 get that look
at her wholeness see that lady just you
just don't know your name is literally
take photos holding deadly octopus I
would too you don't realize
you're like this can't kill me that's a
little that's awesome oh no I would do
that no no no this Nature's listen if
there's an animal out there in rare
cases there's some that are harmless if
an animal looks like a [ __ ] car like
a fancy like Lamborghini they have dots
on it they're bright colors yes it's
gonna get you it's poisonous frogs
that's true all of them nature does it
on purpose go hey humans don't [ __ ] with
these yeah the coral resting dangerous
as [ __ ] think about it that little blue
thing my kids were in Costa Rica we were
on a nature walk and hitting my friend's
kids were were grabbing poison arrow
frogs and getting high well they didn't
grab them but they were like no because
they're they're even the skin can kill
you it's really it's you can prick it
and put on your tongue your kids I was
just like getting those kids even if it
gets on your skin I was like get those
they would grab anything and they didn't
get high or is that fair to land so you
got all kinds they didn't get sick no
because I didn't grab them they didn't
grab them you made that up yeah hey were
they
was there a place that maybe had
poisonous cereal frogs but you didn't
see any right no because that never
happened no we saw we saw we saw it we
saw an eyelash viper I swear he was full
of [ __ ] no I swear to God we did that
never happened and we said we saw I told
you they're there no a guy saw it okay
and there was a and we saw it and it was
on the tree you don't even see it it
mixed with the bark now they call it
beso demo Arte yeah which means the kiss
of death yes now why because it's face
level yeah nice wreck and we saw it
there and if that thing bites you you're
[ __ ] then that's what I saw in Costa
Rica now I don't know if that's true
that I saw them but I I know you did I
believe I didn't see the snake either so
until I saw the snake someone told you
they're there no no I really did no no I
really thought it was it it was brown
the eyelash rapper was brown and bring
up my last Viper because I bet you
they're not brown it was brown it was uh
but they're they're pretty electrical oh
very small now you'll see eyelash fiber
weird not a brown to be seen okay
because they're very bright yellowish
Brown see your line it was a yellowish
because I know what they look like that
one right there that was that's brown
see no those are all the other one right
there that's what it looked like the one
one straight up turkey go down to that
one right there one lower one lower
right there there we go that's what I
saw right there and that thing see how
they blend in with their [ __ ]
environment you forget that their skin
changes he's covered in green though you
know yeah but the point is you didn't
see any of this but it was there was a
change it could have but for the story
like this time I lied to you and Rogan
about the mountain lion right right
right right right see that that's what I
saw that's literally a picture that I
said he's a bluish tip media and that'd
be that'd be almost a white so that
couldn't be fine
dude the kiss of death you got to be
careful muerte
the point is there's another brown one
dude none of them are brown that's even
typed in I lost Viper Brown bro that's a
brown [ __ ] snake he used camouflage
okay you see what I'm saying though
brown and green mixes in with the
[ __ ] bark
yeah and I couldn't believe it and maybe
the one I saw was actually more like
that there it is that's the one
literally the one look at how it sits on
the tree strike you in the face look at
this but nature lets you know how
dangerous look at his head I know they
look so easy it was actually all
[ __ ] aside I really did see one and
it was exactly like that on the tree you
know I lied but that's the truth now
listen there it is there's the one
that's a red that's a red snake that's
the one that's a bright Costa Rica look
at that Costa Rica
it scared me now look I don't [ __ ] with
snakes back to fish dude back to fish so
so you you will have a you will have a
blue ringed octopus I don't know if you
can buy them see if you can buy blue
ring doctor you know piranha is actually
illegal in state California yeah because
they don't have ways though hey yep
well that's like that Sushi hey can I
get your piranha no
yep there's a place to get everything
from whale meat to you know whatever you
want whale meat yes seal blubber
whatever you want now here's the 200
that's a [ __ ] deal wait you can buy
them
look at that
you can just buy that for 200 that's a
cart and it shows up at my [ __ ] house
oh dude dude I'm getting one hey what do
they eat chin I gotta look more into
them who do they get along with you've
got to tell your kids though you can't
have them with the babies your son is
too young and he's too tempting he's
going to be too dude he's gonna be two
times that kid they don't [ __ ] with it
they don't not at all I just don't want
that kid picking up you know he's with
his friends [ __ ] that you gotta lock
that you feed mostly at night on Fish
Blue rhinox was killed or prey with
protein injected with their bite
there are no known threat to blue ring
octopus except for humans
um
Crustaceans they rapidly develop
Brilliant Blue rings
the problem is when you're like you
gotta always gotta clean the tank so I
don't want that liability if I touch it
yeah when you clean that what do you
mean
you get your hands on the tank dude crab
eaters small fish yeah so if they're
with bigger fish not a problem they
usually pounce on their hard shelled
prey trap it with their arms and use
their shirts and have that octopus to
pierce a hole in a pretty shell
okay so okay let's go let's keep going
him yes and I can order him yes
stonefish yes stonefish 100 really just
chill in the in the corner you can buy a
Stone Fish right now the problem is if
you have if you have live Coral the
filtration system's such a beast dude
you don't even see it those fish kind of
suck because they it just looks like a
rock sitting there I like activity dude
that's cool it's so cool that's it 100
100 to 300.
that's crazy
but there's just not going to be a fun
fish to be like you like like Oscars
almost like Oscars almost like dogs dude
you can put your hand in the tank to
come and kiss you they're cool don't you
want one look at that stonefish
Australia I guess if I just want the
most dangerous [ __ ] possible I could do
it no lionfish can I mix nah those would
be kind of cool again clean the tank you
gotta deal with it it's a bit of a beast
oh yeah so you don't want dangerous fish
I don't want poisonous fish I want
dangerous I do piranhas I can do it but
but no so you don't want a blue ring
octopus too dangerous out to us I would
they're beautiful they're so cool
they're worth it that stupid stonefish
is ugly just sits there he's the octopus
I get to see Mosey on around
I like to watch my fish be active that's
why I like fish kills by it's how does a
stonefish kill oh quick it goes home it
hides like the [ __ ] rock dude yes
they're killer fish yeah if you're
eating it'd be fun to watch
yeah
yeah they're at it relied on camouflage
predators
they strike I'm just not into the stone
man did not
okay I'm all about the freshwater fish
right now so at the end of the day
you're gonna get [ __ ] boring assault
oh no no no no no no my my freshwater
fish are lit just get sharks for the
salt water get some sharks
you could
I I swam lemon sharks black tip sharks
yeah I know you've told me this so many
times after a while you're like oh I
need something dangerous I don't you
know what I'm saying like yeah it was a
Mako tiger bull I don't care dude yeah
they're too big no you can do it people
do it baby Bowl yeah I know you did but
uh you could get a baby Bowl oh no they
get too big yeah the Oscars the Oscars
right now are this big they get a foot
big dude you just change a 100 gallon
tank it's a lot they uh they grow a foot
in six months
oh just give me a problem I'll figure
out what it's yeah
now my here's my weird world final
question a weird world move on from fish
boy because you're fishing induce
Bigalow three tanks what's up let's move
on from this how long until you get
bored as [ __ ] a fish
I think right now because the tank is
the the waters with the ammonia and the
nitrates and you gotta work you gotta
test it every day and you know take out
the water make sure the water's safe
yeah you just have to maintain that for
two weeks till it gets perfect then it's
running by itself then I can chill and
just enjoy the fish yeah right now it's
a nightmare yeah but that's why I have
that big tank I'm gonna have that water
up and running for weeks then once that
bad boy's ready boom bunch of fish boom
you're going in that's and that's going
to be in the basement you know all right
it's a lot man okay because if you think
you're just gonna sit back and enjoy if
you want to get the Goldfish the betta
fish those [ __ ] fish you can do that
but if you want like the big boys
they're pooping and eating real [ __ ] the
filtration system has to be popping
daddy cat took all my fish out of my
pond again yeah I have nothing
all of them killed all of them slew
every one of them and I keep hoping that
they're hiding somewhere and they're not
no and uh and they're all they all were
taken the cats killed those big koi fish
yeah it was either a raccoon or a cat or
both
spin spin ideas here make make that pond
Salt Water put in one of those stone
fish and that octopus and let that cat
die on its last set yeah it's gonna die
that's not on me right
this ponds well it's put up a sign
danger do not enter Stone that'd be okay
because they stay at the bottom the
thing is when you got yourself if he's
hungry enough when you got the regular
fish they swim a little too close to the
surface so the cat and the raccoons wait
cats are excellent oh and raccoons just
have hands like we do okay yeah
yeah how big are these koi fish you had
moderate koi fish well I I went on
YouTube and saw a bunch of you know
video of cats killing murdering fish
other excellent Killers oh my God they
just go like that they dip their pawn
and their claws are so sharp that they
just pull that [ __ ] out it's like
hooks you shouldn't get bigger koi fish
in there dude yeah that's all you got to
do yeah I love this koi I I those koi
some of the koi go for you know a
million dollars or some [ __ ] well yeah
see that see how they do that [ __ ] yeah
that cat will take that [ __ ] fish
let's see that cat's not killing those
big fish oh yeah I will yeah they're
pretty good killers
that's a big ass fish yeah
gorgeous too
you're just looking from the top you're
the top view is kind of stupid get a
real tank dude get around you want to
take I'll hook you up hey I got a guy
you want to take I'm gonna take anyone
come over here no no I don't let me
filter your tank no bro no not a filter
tank
I'm not doing I get rid of the chlorine
right yeah he get the right temperature
with bacteria strolling
I'll get attached to my fish oh I'm
that's the thing the smaller tank I'm
more crazy about that because the Oscars
I love the Oscars yeah they're so much
fun yeah not fun but I know what you
mean another fun to watch don't use I
sit my coffee and watch them eat I'm
already bored you know that blood worms
it's fun to mix it up dude it's fun to
mix it up uh I want to thank the people
of Boston for coming out hey how was
Boston New Years Boston is Boston Boston
is Boston's one of the best great place
Boston is a place where you still got
old Boston guys that work with their
hands and then you got uh another Boston
another type of Boston which is
um
there's a there's a highly educated
populace
you know what I like La Colombo yeah I
mean it's a chain yeah I might as well
said you like Starbucks great no way
better way better they're all over me
there's a chain yeah but they've they've
kept their standard up I mean the best
espresso the best coffee yeah all right
much better than espresso than Starbucks
it's a chain hey hey hey it's like you
going you know what I like no you know I
like TGI Fridays no no no no no for my
bunny you're wrong they're french onion
soup dude it's the best in the market
they're not they're not like uh they're
not like uh our place like
Intelligentsia they are there's like two
of them they'll lock clums everywhere
say it correctly everywhere la colombe
maybe but they keep their standards
they're good possibly they're good they
keep all their Baristas marxists and
they keep uh the the roast As Good As It
Gets when you have Communists behind the
counter you know the coffee you know
this humor good they care the only time
I want Communists uh in my life is when
they're making my coffee because they're
so hacking the internet maybe but for
the most part yeah well I don't know if
you've seen this new AI have you seen
this [ __ ] thing I hate it I've seen
this [ __ ] thing dude when you talk
about AI That's like me talking about
fish I hate all Ai No but it scared me
they have um here what is it called you
gotta so we're in trouble we're the
robot are you talking about the the Mick
Jagger one I'm talking about the Mick
Jagger robot
hold on I'm going to show you this I'm
going to show you this
um it's Ai and it kind of blew my
[ __ ] mind but there's a name for it
and if you haven't heard about it just
know that you're going to hear about it
really quickly okay it's called chat GPT
chat have you heard about it isn't this
the one that um freaking Nick did uh
yeah you type in whatever you want it's
so nice it'll write scripts the right
jokes
not only that it's also going to be it
can write code it can write any code you
want it can it literally can [ __ ]
take a paper so you have a paper no I
know kids are doing anything yeah it'll
write the paper they put it again and
run a different paper yeah I mean I wish
I had this when I was in college I know
but the problem is it's literally
smarter so Nick said I think Nick said
that uh when you sign up for it you're
giving away a lot of your information
yeah so that's why it's kind of like you
know well choosing everybody's
information anyway yeah and it can write
in your in your voice and then you can
say right in my voice but like like uh
using Latin or like we had Matt Delia on
you know he's a writer and he's like
there's a actually a writers are
protests in AI because you can write
whatever like write a good story
narrative on this and it will ride it
and they're all different so they can
just hand that out for college papers
people turn in they can turn in college
paper actually that's going to put 50 of
colleges out of business I mean it's
like
academics are writing these things now
you have ai that can do that with all
the information we're just going to
change astonishing papers there's gonna
have to update their [ __ ] with the time
well my question is
what have kids write the paper in class
so movies like are they gonna be able to
write a movie that way and and have well
that's why Matt was saying well that's
why there's literally a protest for
writers in Hollywood against AI they
don't want it coming over to their
movies songs comedy everything
movies songs everything that you can
imagine we out of a job soon
we can't perform it
they could set up something Electronics
what happens but but people are coming
to see the [ __ ] that comes out of my
brain
now I can be like write me a bunch of
jokes yes and AI can actually figure out
what your style of joke writing is and
what your style joke writing is your
comedy and it'll figure it out to make
yeah if that's why it's kind of crazy
now what does that say about plagiarism
like I don't even know what the [ __ ] to
say about this so am I gonna go am I
gonna go to AI
and get up on stage and just recite what
was given to me from a computer do you
understand we probably really doesn't
work that way it might give you some
ideas to get started until it adapts
maybe but what if it writes perfect bits
yeah I mean whether you still got to
perform I I know
so maybe we're grandfathered in and we
get to perform it but
now I mean by the time that's going we
might both be dead
by the time that's like bumping they say
it's gonna in five years or three years
it's going to be ridiculous it's see the
problem is these things are getting
better exponentially right I know that's
the word so everything so so okay so now
you're this is what's really [ __ ]
you're a computer programmer you write
code
this might
replace you right now right now well
think about what the uh Tesla was trying
to do with those automated trucks if
you're a truck driver which my family is
they have those automated trucks where
they just type in one address delivered
this address you don't need the truck
driver who needs brakes and sleep and
pay him hourly you just do this [ __ ]
you pay for that robotic truck and it's
delivering everything back and forth so
truck drivers see you well what about
when they can hack into that truck and
make it go 100 miles an hour and crash
into somewhere hey man this isn't the
movie Speed what's gonna see dude I know
well you just can't stop advancing well
you know what Aaron musk wants to do
Elon Musk wants to create
um he's talking about it's not just him
but like you have to create your own
artificial intelligence system that
protects you from other AI
or if we don't know how to write that
code you're going to have to pay
somebody to do that yeah
yeah the future kind of sucks we're
dinosaurs right now we're dinosaurs I
mean yeah I'm not too worried about it
the future I would say I don't know
where we fit in my friend who's who
makes a lot of money in Tech said no
you're going to mesh with it you're
going to mesh with it you're a dad
everyone does well just well yeah we'll
mesh everyone does but then it's scary
what do I do as a job like what do I do
what do you mean
hey man how do human beings make money
when they're when entire swaths of like
when everything goes away or or is it
just creating new jobs we always deal
with this yeah
well the guy do that was just selling
candles when electricity came along he's
like God damn it yeah people still had
candles yeah I mean your business ain't
booming like it was we got adapt you
start making light bulbs [ __ ] yeah you
know people always deal with this well
they just heard that they did that AI
with uh Obama Barack Obama giving a
speech and they said out of 14 things
who's the real Obama people can pick
because all of them were not the real
Obama
well once you do have Biden we don't
even know he's just his speech is better
his processing's better maybe not
stuttering touching kids to be sick hey
wait what you'll see if you're listening
that's a joke dude of course he's not
he's all right
see a I wouldn't get that see you still
got a job all right I'm not gonna fire
you today all right now we'll see how
where I AI is on Friday true
true and maybe send extra robot
AI scary technology scary in general
yeah
um it's not good I fly coach
and uh
and uh we'll tell Boston it's so
expensive it's so expensive so I fly
coach
and I try to fly a premium economy and
I'm complaining about my seat which is a
larger seat seven inches more room
and then I saw
three seats behind me in a smaller seat
a legit giant poor guy it was so sad he
was direct to La yes six eight but about
350 and all not not fat just a big man
yeah do you ask me what sporty play I
didn't because I saw him walking and I
was like even if he plays basketball or
something he's not bad news uh he's just
walking like a duck with us with a flat
ass he's just a giant man sure mostly
shoulders yeah you know and I thought
about you because I was like
Brennan would want me to ask this guy
with sport but no I wouldn't you would
look at him and go no he's not an
athlete like you know what I mean just
because he's huge doesn't mean you play
football and if he did it might have
been high school yeah and he got up he
got up in the middle of the flight and I
saw him standing there and he was
holding his back he ripped a big fart no
he's holding his back and I said you
shouldn't have drank so much milk you
stupid [ __ ] giant hell yeah you said
and then you killed him and then you
taped duct taped them to the [ __ ]
seat and said you get up again yeah and
these are gonna get busy yeah and I and
I peppered his stupid background behind
him and I punched him they gave him a
massage
I socked this kidney hell yeah pissing
blood sat down and then he passed away
yeah he died I was hoping that story
went and then I want to feed him to the
Piranhas yeah see now we're talking dude
you know that now with the human body
you can have you can cremate them you
can you can get cremated you can get
buried what's the other thing you can do
now uh embalm them you can do that too
what's uh what's the new service that's
now been made legal
uh download their brain okay good you
can you can download the Consciousness
you can have them
disintegrate into what's called compost
you can compost the body now let me tell
you how that works you take you can use
you can turn I can turn you into
fertilizer yeah it's gonna be a three
month process
take your body
I'm gonna put it in a sealed canister
with some Alfalfa some hay okay let the
microbes do their work sure break down
the body and what happens is I'm going
to get a bunch of what looks like soil
yeah I'm gonna get soil you're just
gonna you're gonna be broken down you're
gonna decompose this is for a Greener
lawn three months okay well yep now now
we're gonna add some other stuff for a
lot of guy nitrogen whatever it is
and now I'm gonna have I'm gonna be
given a giant
[ __ ] bag of fertilizer that I can
plant tomatoes or flowers with or
whatever now they're going to put it
through a process where they kill all
the microbes so there isn't any disease
in there I don't want this I don't
either I don't want to I don't be
cremated soil I don't like cremation
either I don't need sounds aggressive
you're gonna burn my body do you want to
eat me eating my worms you know what I
mean well enough I'm in a in a coffin I
think I want to be cremated see Adam is
your body's just set up on fire toasted
yeah and then just like ashes no I want
what the cartels got to do I want a big
thing you come in it's like playing
video like your cartel does like it's
basically a small apartment dedicated to
me you walk in and plays music This Is
How We Do It people coming like [ __ ]
dude and there's a bartender just
serving tiger thick oh really
well you can also do what other people
do you embalm the Bible we always see
you there what you're just there your
body see that's what I want those are
cartel coffins those are actual cartel
coffins you can live up top
oh boy I just want some Instagram [ __ ]
living up top yikes Lewin rent free yeah
hook it up with dudes
that is so excessive right there and
obnoxious
man that's an easy look at that such an
ego
yeah and those places are the same
places off Venice Beach up there look at
that condo
hey but B you heard me it's on my record
that's what I want 650k
I'll raise the money I'll do a stand-up
thing but I'm probably not gonna be in
Malibu you're probably gonna put me in
like Oxnard or something right well I
mean I might be in man's expensive
that's what I'm thinking yeah you might
have to put me in like Ojai or something
I gotta buy a plot I don't have the plot
of land to build a small condo dedicated
to me it's expensive and then you have
to pay the bartender yeah hourly yeah
but here's my thinking though pays for
itself upstairs small one-bedroom
apartment some Instagram thought up
there only fans yeah she's [ __ ]
weiner to pay the bills pay off that
tombstone
you could be crying businessman you
could be cryogenically frozen yeah like
Batman Forever Arnold Schwarzenegger
wife Disney did that so dumb
Walt Disney did that Walt Disney is that
thinking technology catch up with him it
eventually well why do you want to be
reborn into your body anyway you were an
old man if you didn't do that you'd do
it when you're like 24. yeah it's quite
the risk it's you had a bank on
technology picking up probably not dude
no
if you did it when you were in your
Prime like 24
physically what was what's a man's Prime
I think 30 is when you get like grown
man strength yeah what's an athlete Peak
usually in football it depends 30s like
like the the freaking Godfather no
that's when they go downhill at 30.
running backs just running backs not
quarterbacks not quarterbacks
Tom Brady did very well yesterday
yeah they still won their conference if
you had to bet
if you had to bet who are you going to
see in the in in who are the final four
teams do you think uh if Jalen hurts
gets healthy I'll take the the Eagles
he's a stud I'll take the Niners the
Chiefs and the bills
it's a very good bet yeah very pretty
good bet it's a very good but you give
me four teams yeah don't sleep on Green
Bay either coming in hot with Aaron
Rodgers everyone's clowning them now
they're they're getting they win next
week against Detroit they're in they're
in but Detroit is a hot team too it's
all about who's hot tall order even the
giants made the playoffs yeah I'm not
worried about them yeah but but I don't
know about Green Bay although they've
been so hot dude I know Aaron Rodgers
yeah I don't know what people want to
hate on that guy
um Tom Brady going through a divorce now
he's doing better interesting
weird right interesting hey you know
better against Tom Brady no I want to
bet against my brother he's like no way
Tampa Bay makes the playoffs I'm like
you're in your mind dude but against Tom
Brady he'll figure it out he's sad right
now came back in the fourth quarter Tom
Brady
what was that
should we go on the hallway I think so
what the hell did somebody have a
piranha thing let's go outside he's
being crazy and killing people and then
we have to go we'll be right back let me
ask you a question when you wake up do
you check your credit score dude every
day yeah most people don't okay but a
chime that is exactly what they do chime
has a secured chime credit Builder Visa
credit card and you can start building
credit with your own money okay and it
reports your payments to credit bureaus
to help you build credit over time and
their members see an increase of 30
points on average all of this with no
annual fees no large security deposits
no credit checks to apply remember
seeing increase of 30 points on average
all this with no annual fees large
security deposits or credit checks to
apply this is nuts so start your credit
Journey with chime sign up takes two
minutes and it doesn't affect your
credit score get start at chime.com
fighter that's chime.com fighter chime
credit Builder chair abuse credit card
is issued by stride bank and a pursuit
of license Visa USA time checking
accountant 200 qualifying direct deposit
required to apply to the Securities time
credit build Visa credit card regular
time payment history can have a positive
impact on your credit score impact on
the Square may vary and uses scores may
not improve out of network ATM
withdrawal fees May apply except for
money pass ATMs at 7-Eleven or Allpoint
or VISA plus Alliance ATM if you're
still listening that's time.com fighter
look man you need to sleep bro bro I
just had my dad stay with me and he
wouldn't get out of bed I know Dad what
is going on he goes this mattress is too
good
that's what he said Helix look they
really are amazing mattresses you can
take a quiz they will match you to the
kind of sleeper you are side sleeper
back sleeper tummy sleeper if you're an
infant either way they got 14 unique
different mattresses
I know my bunny sleeps on so look you
just find take the quiz find out what's
best for your mattress and by the way
sleep on it for a hundred nights
risk-free if you don't like it they'll
come and pick it up for you and they
ship it to your door for free all right
I took this sleep quiz I was matched
with the perfect mattress because I
wanted something that was firm I sleep
on my side and I love it all right
they're delivered right right to your
door 10 to 15 year warranty depend on
the model so they got you covered Man
Award number one Mattress By GQ and
Wired Magazine it's even recommended by
multiple leading chiropractors and
doctors of sleep medicine as a go-to
solution can you give them 200 off
disorders and two free pillows yes I'll
give you 200 bucks off and two free
pillows go to Helix sleep.com slash
fighter that's Helix sleep and that's
h-e-l-i-x sleep.com slash fighter with
Helix better sleep starts now
what was it huh
some guy with a machete and uh yeah oh
my God we had to uh kill him and we uh
we put his body in a canister and now
he's going to be compost so we're gonna
grow some food with his body nice Brian
killed a guy that was close that was
checked it out yeah there's completely
nothing there we have any fights to talk
about coming nothing nothing at all
nothing
scrounging huh this is what I'm this is
what I'm looking forward to the football
season this one I get very into football
yeah Natty championships coming up on
Monday yeah uh yep NFL playoffs starting
UFC don't really pick up next Saturday
decent if the pay-per-view and middle of
July like like 21st our Rose our Rose
named Scott
um submitted you got Tapped Out yeah wow
the big fight is uh the George is
fighting on Saturday Commerce
boy Georgie God damn it bro oh big
George that's me SSP Fight Night 52.
Commerce Casino Commerce Casino all ages
event are you nervous buddy not really I
mean it's another guy
huh you're gonna have a real fight who's
the guy uh a gay a guy named uh
okay and then then uh tall George is
fighting too it's that uh that um
Ulta program so they take guys who have
never fought before they get world-class
training they were trained with uh
Almeida for 30 30 weeks wow and then
they learn all aspects MMA and then they
can decide at the end if they want to
take a fight or not both George decide
to take a fight yeah okay that's yours
too yeah it's all George yeah he's
athletic yeah SSP Fight Night 52 I don't
know what happened with the first 51 but
all you care about is 52. are you guys
training every day every weekday yeah
Monday through Friday 7 A.M dude
straight that's I'm really in real
dedicated I'm impressed with you and how
many people did you start with George
about 20 something and how many are left
four or five people just especially
during the holidays
I'm really impressed from what George
has come from to this isn't that crazy I
don't know what happened to you but you
are going to be I'm telling you you're
going to be a successful [ __ ]
and don't don't kid yourself you are
you're doing everything that someone
should do you've reinvented your entire
life and it's so impressive will [ __ ]
you up right now I bet he will come get
some dude it's a little motivation for
my boys that's all I need I'm I'm a
witness to it and I'm proud to know you
crazy right I find it [ __ ] from a
video on a podcast tonight fighting
what's craziest January nobody's gonna
be watching your fight because they're
all going to be at mic drop comedy club
in San Diego I don't want to make it
about me but my crop Comedy Club oh man
two shows I know and well and January
6th too so don't do it then and don't do
it January 5th and I and I hate to do
this because Vegas ain't coming out
either George because I'm in Vegas Wise
Guys Wise Guys January 5th through the
7th dude and they were all talking about
going but like oh my God they were so
conflicted I said guys you know the
shows are damn they're sold out but
please come still to my show and listen
California is obviously going to come to
either on my show your show they're
going to be so torn that they're
probably going to stay put and then
they'll go to your fight but we will I
will tweet it about it you don't want to
miss it I'll take the trickle Downs yes
dude tweet about it this can be fun it's
gonna be super fun yeah bar star MMA
it's great and then you should be
ringside he can tap you in in case he
starts to lose
well the Georgians know they lose don't
come back Monday right so you've
disgraced the entire brand
yep the entire freaking brand yep yep
yep Jim what do you got buddy
uh okay we'll start off with
really sad news I'm not sure what's
happening as far as updates on this guy
but you know Jeremy Renner yeah I love
him apparently he's in critical but
stable condition after a snow plowing
accident and what I read it was like
some sort of snow plow in his area he
was trying to clear it up for people to
leave you know his family to leave but
then the snowplow somehow ran over his
leg and then it law he lost a ton of
blood he had to be choppered out to uh
the emergency room Jesus so he's
critical but stable wow yeah that's
awful yeah it is my dad lost his fingers
from a snowplow oh
ripped off three of them he lost one he
lost I forget which one it is might be
this uh I don't know it's either I
forget which one it is now but two of
his knuckles are fake they were able to
sew on two of them he lost one
so he so I think this is the type of
snow plow there's like an actual huge oh
no my dad was using a snow blower yeah
he wasn't using this thing from Fast and
Furious 19. Jesus Christ now look at him
Flex on people like check out the
snowplow and then it got him huh Jesus
but critical that that's that's such a
shame such a good actor too that's
amazing he's super smart
yeah so um but we don't know anything
else there's no as far as he's unstable
though I can um refresh her but I mean
I'm just going to lose a leg the Idaho
killer okay finally got him well they
think he's a suspect right so uh he's so
he's a PhD student yeah he's a piece of
[ __ ] but like a black sheep PhD yeah
yeah they've interviewed some of his
classmates and then also well look at
him his car was at the scene during the
murders that's how they caught him they
got video uh footage apparently it
matched his car and then they caught him
in I forget where Costa Rica somewhere
far from the murder he escaped no it was
not it was in North Carolina yeah he got
extradited from North Carolina back to
North Dakota yeah by the way he's um the
FBI they know what they're doing it's
not like he's not the guy I mean maybe
oh no he's the guy I mean if you gave me
a lineup of 20 people I'm looking at him
like well that guy I see too much serial
killer stuff well that guy
oh no no the guy the white male that guy
that's your killer
you mean with the dead eyes with the
with the dark pools for eyes
with the [ __ ] blue ring octopus eyes
[ __ ] kidding me he does look like
shady sucks to say just off of looks but
ah it is what it is Chick the FBI's on
this [ __ ]
yeah Black Sheep background like right
here they got his dumb stuff like he
tried to break my window there but he is
a strange looking cat man the big eyes
eyes like a grouper fish man I don't
want to make everything about fish but
his eyes are very fishy
oh that's a killer dude
what she's innocent
hey Shopper you're talking [ __ ] about my
eyes told me it is I don't know oh no
he's dead he's a murderer all day this
car was there during the murders Ben
leaves yeah
well let me see his background
background search surface including the
Notions the black sheep in his field of
studies I understand the Criminal Mind
uh keep going down
I don't remember that
uh and his Reds first performance we
could do about our four families who
lost their precious children yep
okay keep going down like I definitely
did it and his face in other words
they're standing by Brian for now
uh what's this
the time it was coming on the heels of
troubling profile that's emerging one of
an outsider who's obsessed over
dissecting the mind of murder to a T
hmm
uh I spoke to half O'Brien's former
classmates and colleagues while he
attended the Styles University in
Washington State University pursuing
degrees in criminology by most counts he
was deeply entrenched in his major but
to a point that was often combative
which reportedly led to conflict in his
life
yeah look at those look at those kids I
kept my wife
he wants he once got in a heated
discussion with another fellow PhD
student about criminology concept and
was accused of me explaining to the
woman she got so upset over the
conversation that she left the class all
right
uh okay go down and he was supposedly
harsh grader leaving notes on the paper
it got so bad the students complained
and masses sounds like I'm pretty
dedicated to his stuff it's like as a
group
um
well
gorgeous girls look at that look at
those girls they were beautiful oh it's
such a it's so such a shame it's such a
shame
I can't imagine
I wonder why he killed them though a
thrill
Ed this profiler was like he they he
said he doesn't live far keep scrolling
down too he doesn't live far from here
he's probably done it before but this
time he got to do it to four people it
was it was a thrill
you keep doing it in the mic hell yeah
he's still getting over a sickness bro
right yeah are you still sick shut up
you still sick Daddy no you're annoying
me you just got a throat problem I just
went like this oh no oh no it's all no
it's definitely not then I'll show you
want me I'll say you want me to do it
every time so you know it definitely is
not I'll do it every time you do it
watch just so you're aware I don't care
I'm used to it yeah Daddy you know what
it is it might be the mocha
there's green phlegm no man it's not bro
okay okay
that guy's definitely kill her though
I need your looks it sucks to say but if
the FBI listen FBI doesn't make too many
mistakes when they [ __ ] extradine
their behavioral units yeah I mean the
but the video I saw literally as cars
there during the murders then gone after
the murders yeah okay salt I've seen too
much First 48 yeah
yeah yeah
it's um
suspect Idaho's killer was more animated
after the slangs look at him he was more
animated yeah
yeah well you know he felt probably like
he had accomplished something and got
away with it holy [ __ ] police say 19
000 tips LED them to the arrest in Idaho
murder suspect acted alone damn how the
[ __ ] did he kill four people they lived
in different rooms I guess they were
sleeping and he came in
yeah what a bad dude yeah I mean this is
a guy serial killers get off on the
actors
well he may be well there's a murder I
think in Oregon that they're associating
it with of this couple that was randomly
killed so they think he might be
associated with that sure he got off on
that stuff
but they're saying the murder scene was
off like it was sloppy too so it's not
like he's a Dexter you know yeah he was
pretty sloppy left his dnas uh they
found his DNA he has blood too yeah well
so that they they it's like um
apparently a lot of those guys it's like
they're they're having a sexual
experience like that's why they go back
to the emergency yes yes they catch them
that way yeah
like this one time thing is the serial
killer I think they caught the Green
River Killer that way because this guy
Richard Walter was saying he said you'll
find him in his car jerking off at one
of the Mercedes yes yeah sure enough
yeah they go back to it or they save
mementos from it like a necklace or
something oh yeah
creeps at least they caught them those
police were taking heat because there
was no suspects I told you that they did
this group of guys used to hang out with
everybody they were all friends and
there was one guy was always quiet found
out he was that he they caught a serial
killer I guess he was feeding these
bodies to the Hogs okay he was the guy
in their group kind of a quiet guy you
know regular guy like where's Kevin at
every Saturday yeah just Kevin where's
Kevin at every Saturday exactly Kevin's
murdering people yeah
you never know yeah chin
I'm just saying a lot I suspected I mean
listen if cops came here I can't we're
not trying to cause any trouble bodies
have been missing and and you know we
don't know what's going on but it leads
us back together
to interview him first before I even
finished I finished the sentence you
know there's some been bodies Mr Chen
it's chin he's like listen I'm not
saying anybody in the room Jen
interviewed him first give him the lie
detector you know they don't really do
lie detectors anymore we should we
should do that no they're too faulty
yeah I've talked to guys who give lie
detector tests and they told me that
they are totally accurate but they don't
they don't hold up in court anymore they
don't do them anymore if you feel no
guilt how would you yeah and also the
high uh blood pressure they're too dicey
yeah not an O.J Simpson fail one yes he
did and they never reported it he took
one before they started the trial before
it posted a whole thing about why would
you want to have a Simpson on to us to
people in general who are thinking about
having them on a podcast and what did he
say he murders people yeah I mean
because the court begs to differ
yeah I mean you know I mean there's
right there's gray and everything seems
like how many clicks do you want you
know but
interested in interviewing him because
he's an American
character he's part of the American
landscape well would you interview
Charles Manson if he's live
he's more famous than OJ Simpson he's
not because he's just crazy you think OJ
said
um I would ask Charles Manson about the
MK Ultra program ooh me too and I'd ask
him about you know this the LSD I'll ask
him about the spawn Ranch but he was
already a criminal you know oh lifelong
criminals yeah he was a kid so I I wait
so you'd have monitor now you just said
you'd ask him questions
that means you should have them on I
don't know would you have Bill Cosby on
no
but to your point that where you're
saying that these people are American
like in American history
you draw the line with OJ
mm-hmm
I truly believe that you know Bill Cosby
did all that stuff okay I don't think
there's any doubt about it so for me I
have no interest in being around a guy
like that you think OJ's innocent I
don't I didn't follow the case very well
but you did I did what are the chances
he's innocent not good yeah yeah I'm not
listen to those I could give you some
that you would be entertained by yeah
but then in the day again to the head do
you do it probably yeah so so to your
point we wouldn't have a bond here's the
other thing we at the time thought we
could have them on because we heard he
was doing podcast runs hey he can't come
to the state of California for legal
reasons so that ain't happening B just
have mod minimum you got to pay him 100
Grand oh really I ain't paying him 100
Grand no no
no
100 Grand 100 and you can't talk about
any of the murders Nicole Kidman none of
that stuff so so our uh we're gonna talk
about football almost making some money
not really 100 Grand how many podcasts
has he been on if OJ had a football show
on YouTube I don't think you'll do well
no no too too old too out of that no he
murdered people right so you're not
going to give him you know you click on
his football picks yeah he moved on but
yeah especially Millennials and like the
younger audience they don't know him as
a football player yeah
I don't know who would click on it and
now he does the sad thing is he does
know a thing or two about football yeah
you know and he does some content on his
Twitter about football but I don't know
who's really clicking on it
you could try it I'm sure I'm sure
there's some audience there I don't I
don't know that's a good question but
you'd have him on
I don't think I would
I mean I think a journalist said okay
let me ask you I don't know for the guys
there are journalists serious
journalists from serious Publications
that would interview OJ now
does that make them bad
like what what about different job like
we're in the business of entertainment
okay but we're not also hey we're not
journalists no I know she comes on here
and we can't talk about murder because
if he agrees to an interview with say
Dan Rather something like that like that
serious Barbara Walters or like a Larry
King style interview he's gonna he's
going on knowing he's gonna have to
defend himself talk about murder he
comes on here put him 100K you can't
talk about murder
okay what's up football
yeah it's not our job like we're not the
platform for it yeah
that's like with Liberty when he asked
me to come on the show to talk about you
know we got busterism like we're not the
place for it man yeah we [ __ ] around a
lot I'm not a journalist I don't care go
on schultzy show because he's he doesn't
know you like I know you and he'll bust
your balls and hold your feet to the
fire but also make you look good and bad
like me and Brian won't we like you like
we're not it's not I'm not journalist
dude I don't have any journalist
Integrity I don't give a [ __ ] yeah we're
in the business of Comedy messing around
so you have OJ out here
well yeah I guess did you remember when
Marshall remember Marshall Clark was
doing the rounds she had a book come out
and they asked her to be on the show
yeah and I was like oh I have so many
questions for her one condition you
can't talk about the OJ case well then
why would I have her on we're going to
have her on for
eign
[Music]
I'm out yeah
what else we're gonna talk about well
there is a with OJ there is a kind of
thing right there's a spectacle where
you go people are they tune in because
they want to see
what life is like for a guy like that
now
go away with murder yes so the question
would really be the the question would
be you went away for nine years what's
changed in the nine years
how has your life changed do you think
back pre-event
versus past event what have you lost you
know all those things if he's open to it
well those are those are general
questions I know what's life for you
like today on a daily basis yeah after
all the deal with after after everything
happened how has life changed for you
like when you walk in a restaurant how
do you feel you know that would be
interesting I guess
we're just not I don't know for the
right media for it I don't know I think
it'd be interesting
me too I wouldn't pay him 100 Grand the
chance no I thought it was free no me
too
but he can't come to California anyways
yeah and we're not traveling for it no
he's in Vegas where is he I think Vegas
now yeah or Florida
yeah yeah
I wonder where you draw the line because
you know there's people out there that
I think when we talk about murder it's a
little different right but I think
like where do you draw the line because
there's people out there who have made
mistakes went to prison for it came out
and now they're in the spotlight and
they're doing better now
you have those people on you okay so you
guys he moved to Miami Florida so he
didn't have to pay he didn't have to pay
the liability judgment yes
okay
handsome guy boy when he was young oh
yeah
the whole world for himself yeah because
certain people out there that have made
some some horrible things and came back
you know paid their dues yeah and we as
Society we forget about them
not murder not not cutting the heads off
of two innocent people
a woman he I guess had had a history of
abusing
yeah deep history cops came to his house
multiple times there's recordings of it
yeah and when his sister found out she
screamed he did it he finally did it so
you know for those families
um yeah I don't think I would do it I
wouldn't do it out of respect for the
families for for Ron Goldman his his dad
and uh and his mom I wouldn't do it [ __ ]
that
I don't want them to see that I I just I
think it's I think it's I don't know if
they're watching fine but I like I like
where you had that I don't want to be a
source of anybody's pain I we have
children man I'm with you
Charles Manson's this one because
technically he never killed anybody
yeah but he's Orchestra followers yeah
[ __ ] that guy too
he died right oh yeah yeah cancer [ __ ]
that guy too
you know they label a serial killer but
he never killed anybody
it's an interesting one
strange
let's take a moment of silence
would you rather have O.J Simpson or
Bill Cosby
O.J Simpson me too yeah
yeah you ever seen The Bill Cosby thing
when they bring up the case well you
have 50 to 80 women oh but this is this
is like this is like mid like late 90s
he's doing a major interview with like
Dateline like major interview with his
wife next to him yeah and they bring it
up and they they kept recording someone
to decided and he thought the cameras
were off and he goes hey that question
take that out edit all that and see what
happens if that makes this interview
they took it out
wow yeah he was super controlling
well you know
when you have that many women telling
the same story you got a problem
[ __ ] how's he keep giving out I
thought he was he was in prison he got
out because it was so long ago so the
statute of limitations because you know
it's the evidence is he should see he
said she said okay
yeah and then he announced his tour
dates that's amazing isn't that crazy
who's gonna pick up what what where is
he gonna find a venue that will let him
do that I don't nobody announce tour
days go to his tour day thing
click on why wasn't Bill Cosby released
from prison
because he was released from prison
we need to talk about we talked about
this before in the show there was some
sort of loophole something happened oh
it was just like double jeopardy kind of
yeah like I said someone talked about
the case something when they shouldn't
have and because of that no I thought
because he admitted to it once they
couldn't find him a second time there
was like a loophole in the in the paper
filing too right she admitted it when he
was not supposed to admit it like it
wasn't in court something like that some
weird stupid loophole everyone knows
he's so Cosby was found guilty by a jury
of three accounts of aggrade indecent
assault against a bunch of girls you
sent it to uh three to ten years and
state prison received a 25 000 fine plus
Court
he was released three years later okay
his convictions were overturned after
serving nearly three years
um over time
yeah that's what it was due processes
requirements must respect all legal
rights owed to a person in the court of
law since December 2019 Cosby's he may
have been been appealed oh here it is B
however the major turnpoint came when
the court also agreed to review whether
a Cosby's constitutional rights have
been violated during the 2018 trial when
evidence was used from 2005 civil
lawsuit brought
um in February stay in the press release
saying the convention was unattainable
declined his criminally charged Cosby
I remember something like he confesses
something but you had to deal in a
certain Manner and they used that which
they couldn't have done since Cosby was
told by a Caster he would not ever be
criminally prosecuted in the constrained
matter as a result because we agreed to
testify in the civil lawsuit we're
admitted given that girl uh in includes
Quaaludes and other women Quaaludes
so he agreed to it but he agreed to it
he was into having sex with a woman
unconscious
yeah it's dark
so Cosby Lou team argue Cosby had been
had agreed to testify in his civil case
under the promise he would never face
prosecution and criminal case based on
promises made by the prosecution
yeah so that means this process right
violated
well
there you go
so then but then now there's more women
going out and so he has to defend that
too but they can't prosecute him right
since he
no he kind of got clemency
wow
can't see either he's blind oh his eyes
are insane he's 85 dude
bring up his tour dates what venues is
he at
Bill Cosby tour dates I'm not telling
you announce the tour beat I'm just
talking about he wants to talk no no no
no B I'm telling you
finds a tour in 2023 no
yeah he's eyeing it
I don't think he has tour dates Bubba
let's see if he has a website yeah if
you go back it looked like it was on
there
here Crosby tickets yep there you go
no upcoming snow so he's probably
planning on it but he's hoping he can
good luck I mean who's gonna people will
go they will go what venue we'll host
him what venue can he get to host him
FairPoint not Live Nation nobody like
that is gonna host that guy so where
where are you going to do it yeah who's
going to take on that you'd have to
you'd have to rent out your own space I
guess oh you'd have to rent theaters his
own theaters yeah then you need
insurance who's going to insure you you
need I don't know
yeah I don't know
weird yeah who's going to that show
that 85 year old Bill Cosby who's blind
he'll sell out no no people will go
always go 100 percent yeah
but damn is he selling merch do you
think uh 100 he's selling merch
well there is a good amount of people
thinking it's all [ __ ] it's just a
media thing they're coming after him
really oh yeah
all right because you would actually
paid to see him perform there's there's
a market there
it's weird huh
very strange
very strange
like if O.J Simpson a one-man show like
Tyson had I better do pretty well
there are people there are people that
have them on
uh on their stage yeah there's certain
parts of the world
all the parts of America yeah I think I
don't know yeah I don't know I'd be very
surprised
Cosby I'd be surprised O.J Simpson
one-man show he could get it done it's
been long enough time yeah let's go get
it done
yeah
strange huh yes what else you got Jen
one last thing on that the the whole if
he's innocent or not you know we all
kind of believe that Cosby or OJ uh OG
RJ OJ but remember the big thing with
that I remember this because I was I you
know
I'm Korean and I saw all the Korean
business owners and doing you know with
the the k47s all the riots it was uh
somewhere somewhere in L.A who's the
watch right okay so anyway so there's a
I remember the riots after Rodney King
which was in one so the reason why the
writers the Rodney King trial just
happened and there was this huge thing
like it was a cultural thing it was the
first time anything really crazy
happened
so the OJ Simpson's channel is right
after that and of course if you're a
human being and you're a juror you don't
want that [ __ ] to happen again so that's
probably you know a real big reason why
they let it oh they definitely factored
in like the Rodney King beating the the
the
business is getting destroyed the
backlash they would receive from the
riots I'm sure they're like all right we
let this one guy off or like what's
better for society that's what I feel
like watch Rise by the way I believe
we're in the 60s that's what I thought
too those but go to the Los Angeles so
South Central watts is in South Central
right yeah yes uh no watts is I don't
know if it's South I thought it was like
in the east coast I don't know any place
no Watts the Watts Riots let's just
Google Watson
um
yeah
yeah see this is uh 65 yeah that's why I
was like the Watts thing yeah the watch
Rebellion watch Uprising to play so so
when the riots happened during Rodney
King where was that but where were the
rotting I think it was South Central
with this look yeah so why did I think
South Central is in
yeah South Central
yeah
go down to and go to what city said
rights in 1992. pretty much all of them
in L.A
yeah crazy
interesting yeah but I couldn't believe
it I'm with you I'm with you that had a
big factor in it yeah it's
like and the prosecution dropped the
ball too a bunch like when uh homeboy
tried the glove they told him not to do
it that Marcia Clark told him not to do
that and he was kind of a new prosecutor
and did it and when OJ obviously he's an
actor too and it didn't fit and if it
doesn't fit you must have quit like they
they dropped them too I mean he he cried
after that that prosecutor told him to
stop love he cried man because he
royally [ __ ] up
and if just just us here in this room
thinking if I'm going to leave something
behind I'm gonna leave some behind
that's going to be not matching what I'm
gonna [ __ ] fit my hand in I would do
that on purpose that's interesting would
you not
well murderer no I'm just taking your
hands my DNA was all over what I'm
saying I would leave something that it's
like obviously not you know that's not
gonna fit me yeah come on why would that
glove shrunk but were they [ __ ] up
with it get that glove probably was his
but it was uh covered in blood so in the
by the time the trial came along that
blood seeped in and they said it
actually Shrunk the glove too would you
deal with a number of factors it's true
did do you um did was there DNA where
was the DNA in his in his Bronco the DNA
of him was in his Bronco blood
uh I don't know if there's was in it no
there was no that's been a drop but this
is also
it's found in a socks this is Bronco oh
Goldman's blood was found in his Bronco
wait Brown's blood was found the
national glove was found on his bedroom
and Goldman's blood was found in
Simpsons Bronco all but one drop
but here here's why else he got off chin
and this what makes uh Johnny Cochran
brilliant that cop remember that cop
they found to be racist and they they
accuse him
very good detective apparently very good
detective but the the defense team made
that the narrative that they like LAPD
was racist you don't have to OJ Simpson
they record him using the n-word a few
times but they made the whole narrative
around that that LAPD was racist during
that time that Mark Fuhrman was known as
a good cop but would drop the n-word
from time to time but he wasn't like a
leader of the KKK but they made him seem
that way so you have those black jurors
you have this racist cop the accused of
hiding evidence so that whole narrative
just put a doubt in everybody's mind as
well and it was the height of the riots
and the Rodney King racist cop lapd's
racist so it was like this perfect did
he kill them
in his old house or or at her at her
house at her at her townhouse then they
found the glove behind his his
from both of them no they found that
glove at the murder scene not his house
yeah you see that they were leather
gloves had not been worn in several
months the other gloves in order to fit
so ugly stretch up it when they're worn
they stay stretched out for prayer time
but shrink back slightly when they're
not worn also covered in blood yeah
it said the the blood was from the the
two victims though but his yep so yeah
and then he had cuts on his hand they
called him because he took a plane that
night from LA to Chicago
and they said when they called him he
was like oh my God you know like he was
like most people would be he was just
like I better get back and like that's
weird then when they got him the next
day hit cuts on his hands he said it was
from like you know doing housework or
something like that
um damn yeah well I'm pretty sure we all
agree probably yeah did it yeah I mean
yeah or hired someone to do it the the
conspiracy is his older son his older
son has really bad anger issues
I don't know and then you know Nicole
Kidman you know she was divorced so more
power to her she's going around town you
know with other guys hooking up with
people Nicole Simpson Nicole Brown
Nicole Brown yeah
all right so this happened recently too
well I don't have any more what's your
take on this public Andrew Tate he was
arrested for this is fake though he was
in a traffic no he wasn't just on New
York Times it's fake but so he was he
was taking not custody right but it's
fake not not for trafficking rape in
Romania that's that's a fake headline
yeah that's what everybody thought and
that was the narrative but he was not
arrested for that
yeah and the New York Times ran with
that
well uh although he's still saying that
yeah
well so that's three days ago
so it originally came out that he was
accused of rape and trafficking and
that's not what the actual case is so
then originally it did come out that way
but then it so this is three days old
three days but then here's one hour ago
it's New York Post
I don't know I thought it was tax
evasion
yeah it's something with money like
laundering but it's not rape and uh
trafficking
organized crime and terrorism Bucharest
so that might be investigated for
organization crime and terrorism and
Bucharest yeah but the headlines all
came out right rape and sexual [ __ ]
so arrested Thursday if I let you run
organized crime group that traffic women
force them to create porn but we've seen
specialized website for a cost
yeah he was running some kind of like
only fans thing right and then
I don't know
videos of one victim suspected generate
nearly 55 000 a month while she's paid
nothing
Tate replay said that the woman kept 80
to 85 of the income from the videos most
of the girls end up being
multi-millionaires Tate was arrested
along with his brother Tristan who's 34
two alleged female accomplished during a
raid on the compound were cashing guns
were seized you know how they caught him
it's pizza box
he did a video going back to that uh
with that environmental Greta
Thunderbird Greta Thunder
Greta so he he did a video because she
was making fun of him and he did a video
back to her he had a pizza box on his
desk so the authorities were able to see
that pizza box and realize he's like
yeah I watched the pizza box I watched
the video I haven't seen a video
oh look he's right next to pizza boxes
that that pizza that comes from one
place so they knew he was in his place
in Romania
dude how about the Logan Paul stuff
uh that is what I wanted to get your
take on I know I just remembered it you
and I were talking about it earlier you
know I love Logan yeah I love Logan I'm
waiting for him to come out with his
rebuttal but the guy that's doing well I
had some people brilliant I had some
people look at uh who are very into
crypto and made a lot of money and know
this and they I had them look into the
pump and dumb scheme yeah you know and
that is a pump and dump
you know you you're manipulating the
market to make a lot of money and I
think that's
if that's the case if that's the case we
got a problem
maybe I'm waiting to see because Logan
asked that guy to come on a show it was
like we'll do it on my platform and I
won't monetize it like I'm not looking
to make money off here and then I guess
the guy didn't return back and he was
hey man I'm doing a video I think it
drops today I'm doing a video all you
want to go to meet you at a neutral
location so it's not on your platform or
mine just to get the word out there this
is the king crypto King crypto king or
whatever the guy he he by the way is
another guy he made a lot of money and
you know I got a problem with that guy
too because he kind of basically said
yeah it's unethical that I what I did
it's like come on dude you know yeah so
I I I don't know enough about it but
what I do know is Logan Paul has so much
money he's on his way to become a
billionaire he doesn't really need to do
this oh so Logan did it
oh this guy coffee Zill this guy making
the documentary The crypto kiano who
you're talking about so the crypto Kings
the guy he was involved with but no no
this says a lot about Logan if he did it
with this guy because this guy he knows
questions to ask no oh he did not yet be
so the the coffee Zilla is the guy that
made all the documentaries outing him on
this dad did all the research yeah so
this guy making the videos so this is
Logan news I sent this message to Coffee
Zillow five days ago I haven't heard
back so I'll be recent response to the
scam out games tomorrow on my YouTube
um and this goes through all of it so
that coffee Zillow he's brilliant his
videos are so good knowledgeable guy but
I'm curious I I want to wait till I say
anything till I see what Logan's yeah
I'm talking about
it no I text him on uh Christmas
look I mean I you know I hope I hope
that uh my only thing is listen whenever
these these hit documentaries like this
I always wait to hear the facts
obviously it's a hit piece right to make
Logan look bad and then also the other
guy Logan's working with who kind of put
it all together is in cahoots with
coffee Zilla so you have two guys that
don't like Logan Paul working together
Logan's actually a good dude so I am
curious to see what Logan because and
also the other thing that I give Logan
the benefit of Doubt again he's on his
way to be a billionaire dude people
aren't paying attention the kid's so
rich doesn't mean anything no I'm just
saying he doesn't need to do this and
Logan's a lot of people that don't need
to do it I think that it's possibly get
out in over a skis or there's or his
team talked him into it or I do think
maybe he didn't know what was going on
again I don't know the fact I don't know
the last first thing about crypto or I
think I don't know enough so I don't
want to say anything no I'm waiting to
hear Logan's response
because it it just doesn't make sense
because Logan's not a stupid kid we're
like okay let's do this pump and dump
illegal scheme yeah let's do it because
I need the money you know what I'm
saying
yeah I uh I wish him I hope uh he I hope
he has a good reason and I hope uh
because I do like him and
yeah I I it would just be the stupidest
thing he could do it makes no sense well
you know there are a lot of people that
are where where are the temptation
to create
a coin let's call it and to essentially
the way they do with modern art to get a
small ring of people to buy those coins
and then build it up and then build it
up with your platform and then to sell
what you already own at a higher price
that's a very that's a very tempting
thing the problem with it it is it is
unethical it's taking advantage of I'm
not saying this is what he did no but if
he did yeah that's what it looked like
from the from well yes yeah the hippies
but I don't care about those two pieces
I I gotta wait to hear from the horse's
mouth yeah
whatever documentaries on Netflix like
making a murderer they have an agenda to
get you talking about it they're gonna
put together a narrative although that
makes you go I watched his Sam bankman
free thing he was right on and the
coffee still a guy got into the weeds
with the Logan Paul stuff and it was too
complicated so I sent some friends to
help me explain it I watched it all and
then I watched the breakdown though
still there's an agenda the agenda is
not to make Logan Paul look in any facet
so you gotta take it with a grain of
salt oh they know because his evidence
are bad his evidence the agenda might be
to just say this is what I'm seeing
right the agenda might be also hey this
is a skin there's a lot of scamming that
goes on in in in crypto because so new
yeah multiple there's so many people
that did that yeah anyway I I like Logan
and I hope that I'm wrong yeah I think
he's supposed to his rebuttal today
though which should be Mega views for
that kid
but you know
and for him to address it himself that's
that's the move you know
what else you got Jen yeah I don't know
enough about crypto though I don't know
that world it's so it gets so dicey yeah
and is it regulated it's not like stocks
you know like you know
like how Pelosi was pumping and dumping
I think also I'm watching this entertain
thing it's like if you're gonna play
this game if you're gonna be in this
game if you're going to be in this this
this Twitter sphere this influencer
sphere this crypto sphere
this thing where your money is your
money is contingent upon the number of
clicks and engagement you get
you are playing a dangerous game because
it's a Fickle world man it's a snake
that eats its own tail and you know
to come after Greta Thornburg like this
and all of a sudden boom but but uh he
must have he did it for a reason right
like why would he go after so his
original post was hello at Greta
thundberg I have 33 cars my Bugatti has
a basically uh w16 uh eight liter quad
turbo my two fry a12 which is a
ridiculous guy I have 6.5 liter v12s
this is just a start please provide your
email address so I can send a complete
list on my car collection and the
respective enormous submissions that
card's so ridiculous what kind of car is
that that's a Bugatti how much is that
Chevron uh that's probably four million
yeah how much money does Andrew Tate
have a ton wow and he doesn't come from
money what is he he owns um uh he has
like this no no he has this like uh
website thing it's about
self-improvement with masculine no
that's that's he made his money before
that uh you got a lot of money doing
that no no he has houses yeah but that's
all that no he was making he was rich
but before that he had uh casinos but so
the response that Greta thundberg which
I don't know who's handling her she said
yes he's doing live you know my small
dick energy I get a lifetime.com which
was actually really good I love that she
lit him up oh she lit him up that's her
thing that's [ __ ] great
okay that's great good on there Greta
thundberg and then Andrew made a video
and wrote uh yeah I wrote this Twitter
post and that's when he got busted go
through the pizza box on there
yeah but not a way you want to end 2022
no and she was great on that she won
that she won that exchange everybody
yeah my thing is
foreign
net worth of 355 million dollars yes I
mean as far as we know of I believe
didn't he own why do I think he owned
casinos no Andrew Tate
I think so but
maybe bought one later
that's not where he made his money
though he made it off that casino
University owns 15 Romanian casinos
that's how he's I'm telling you
his early 30s today he has a chain of 15
different casinos generating more than a
million dollars per month in Revenue he
made his money some of his other
business code only fans management
company the real world the War Room
wow yeah there you go
well it makes sense of it that's why
it's so serious he's already rich smart
dude man smart dude
how do you even start to own a casino I
don't know
in the fight world he probably got to
know some pretty shady characters right
I don't know I don't assume I don't know
I was in the fight world I don't know
Shady characters
who is that with a chess player oh did
you guys ever see that oh his dad was an
American chess International Master
wow Grandmaster have you seen him play
chess with uh Pierce Morgan Andrew Tate
no probably crushes him he yeah and
Andrew or sorry Pierce is supposed to be
really really good he destroyed him I
mean as he's talking his dad was a
Trailblazer man that's [ __ ] that's a
a chest he's obviously a super smart guy
yeah even obviously the way he
articulates himself he's a smart dude
it's interesting man it's interesting
how big he got
is his dad still alive I guess so yeah
no it says died 215.
interesting impressive yeah
yeah
interesting who is his mom
and I think Andrew Tate was even more
his name was more was Googled more than
Kanye West that's how big he is now he
was the most Googled at a certain point
wow yeah
I first started making money I retired
my mom my feeling is I believe he's a
good guy and and uh he's trying to help
a lot of dudes out I think he's just got
lost dudes up I don't know he's a fire
brand you know so he's just he's an hour
how to get yeah you know how to get your
attention so he would say some crazy
[ __ ] but people lose their mind nowadays
I do think that there was a their people
wanted to get after him I do think that
well because he said that he said uh
again it could be a conspiracy but he
said on his show that they offer him a
certain amount of money to kind of chill
out on things and I keep going hard in
the paint on the and he was like No And
then he goes by not doing that I knew
they were gonna come after me like I'm
playing a dangerous game here's the
thing about people who are very
successful like this with huge egos they
do push the envelope and they do go a
little too far that's why they have so
much money though yeah but also what
their their biggest strength can also be
their fatal flock and yeah if you don't
control them yeah and you don't think
that the laws of the universe apply to
you and this is the fall so
he's a guy who'll always land on his
feet he's probably got plenty of money
you're also fighting a fight like when
you're fighting with the government and
like you know yeah the left like yeah
when they come for you they come in
they're pretty powerful well everything
in every way I mean they banned them
from is he's the guy you want to ban
from every platform he's the guy wow
you know
yeah
what else you got Jen here's a quick one
you would you would know more about this
idea but the tour
how do you say his name
multiple concussions and then I guess
Jay Glazer pointed out that when he was
talking to here the here's what it says
here
when he was talking to his coach he had
no idea what he what decisions he was
making so he's forgetting things yeah so
people are wanting him to possibly
retire but he wants to come back and
play for them or just if they make the
playoffs yeah I'd sit the year out I
doubt they'd make the playoffs they're
terrible right now but if they were to
not make the playoffs that the year out
get some rest and come back for a
preseason see but I mean see how his
brain is because he had a whole suffered
a horrible concussion the worst we've
ever seen injury and then came right
back yeah
so I think it was some rest he should be
okay
yeah so that was just you know a topic
people want him to retire but I'm sure
he wants to come back and play yeah I
don't think you should play this how
good is he he's good yeah
did he hit what happened he got he fell
back or something yeah hit hit his head
that's when he has really bad concussion
and kept playing
what else you got Jim this is uh this is
probably the last one this is just um
I don't know what's real or what's not
real whatever but so apparently so at
Twitter I don't buy it apparently a
point um employees have to bring their
own toilet paper knob because Elon Musk
uh
laid off like janitors and everything
else so
no one's coming here
is the enemy right now anything he does
entertain and and Elon Musk two
entrepreneurs are the bad guys I guess
so any man who makes a lot of money and
is a trailblazer and successful is the
enemy this is my problem it's like this
is what the [ __ ] mainstream media
spends on but they're mad at Elon
because now he has power right because
he kicked basically was like hold up you
guys were doing this with this platform
whether you're left or right I'm not
putting up with any of it they call him
Chief twist so now they're trying to get
him
yeah like I said I don't know if there's
anything they can do because Elon has
done great things for society right it's
on he isn't the Tesla Mars it's amazing
you can't win these [ __ ] these these
people it's just like dude
but if you but again buy some fish the
far left right that's the thing by Oscar
official buy some futility to the media
people writing this stuff buy some fish
with some box jellyfish some blue ring
octopus see I can't recommend page with
your hands yes it'll be fine but it's
like this like when they write this
thing like bring your own toilet paper
they don't need to that's what's problem
with journalism it's like they don't do
any factors written by [ __ ] chat GPT
or whatever the [ __ ] it is what is it I
think that's right
don't get on your phone be I'm saying
hold on it's written by
chat GPT yeah who's that got it right
that's the AI thing oh oh yeah we're not
gonna know what's right what's wrong
what's true as well so interesting
is that it be
buddy where you at this weekend pal I'm
glad you asked I'm being I'll be in San
Diego
um Comedy Club yeah January 5.7 yeah
nice for you now I gotta go to Fort
Wayne Indiana after that somebody come
Summit comedy cute Town though I like
that place in the club too yeah okay
I'll be there January 13 14. Danny of
Florida January 19 and 20 and 21. okay
yep I see you shaking your head that
should be fun got I'm taking most of
February off I'll be at the comic strip
in Edmonton Canada
uh February 23 24 20. it's toasty up
there for you yeah Nashville Tennessee
Zanies uh I'm in Vegas this week baby
Vegas Sin City Wise Guys January 5th
through the 7th Tampa
uh January 20th through the 21st Friday
Saturday only Tampa Springfield Missouri
February 3rd through the 4th are you
doing the Blue Room in Springfield yeah
yeah there you go yeah so Vegas you're
up this week then Tampa then Springfield
Missouri get your tickets at fatkz or
thick boy.com also get that
award-winning sweet thick nectar at
thickboy.com we just just reloaded we
sold out but we just got more cases in
today so that should be available on
thickboy.com all right all right kids
love you see ya later